As the second of Ridley Scott's Alien prequels,
Alien: Covenant picks up on the themes we
saw in Prometheus and continues to build a
backstory for the Xenomorph we first met in
Scott's 1979 Alien movie.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, it's Jan here
and in this video, I want to take a look at
some of the easter eggs and details in Alien:
Covenant that only die-hard fans will have
spotted.
Do let me know about your favourite easter
eggs or any others you spotted in the comments
below and also subscribe for a chance to win
this awesome Alien: Covenant merchandise.
I've got two packs to give away and each one
includes a T-shirt, a cap, a keychain bottle
opener, metal playing cards and a set of pin
badges.
Obviously, there are spoilers ahead for Alien:
Covenant, so be aware of that or come back
after you've seen the movie.
When the Covenant crew land on the planet,
two of the team are infected with Neomorph
spores after they disturb the local flora
causing the spores to be released into the
air and enter their ear or nostrils.
This airborne means of infection is actually
a call-back to a rejected script for Alien
III by writer William Gibson.
Gibson's story, which would have been the
sequel to director James Cameron's Aliens
movie, explored the theme of genetically altering
Xenomorphs into bioweapons.
And this idea also links to David's experiments
in Alien: Covenant and how he combined the
lethal "black liquid" pathogen with DNA from
the Engineers and Elizabeth Shaw to produce
his own experimental alien creations.
During the confrontation between David and
Walter, David quotes one of the most famous
lines from John Milton's epic poem Paradise
Lost, in which Satan declares, "Better to
reign in Hell than serve in Heaven."
There's a parallel between David's story in
Alien: Covenant and Prometheus and how he
turned against the humans he served, and the
themes of Milton's Paradise Lost which tells
the story of the fallen angel Lucifer, and
how he corrupted mankind in the Garden of
Eden, after he was banished to Hell when he
rebelled against God.
By the way, "Paradise Lost" was the original
title for the Prometheus sequel until it was
changed to "Covenant".
And that title change is interesting because
in the poem "Paradise Lost", Adam experiences
a vision of future events right up until the
Biblical Great Flood, which ties in with the
idea of the covenant God made with Noah who
built the ark that saved humanity and the
animals.
And just like the Biblical story of the ark
and the Great Flood where each species came
in twos, did you notice how all the crew on
the Covenant are couples?
And, at the end of the movie, David himself
also brought a pair of alien embryos onto
the Covenant ship.
And the seed of David's rebellion against
humankind was planted during that opening
scene in Alien: Covenant where we see the
first moments of David's creation and self-awareness
with Peter Weyland.
In that scene in Weyland's room, David names
himself after the statue of Michelangelo's
David, likely because he felt that looking
at the statue of David was, in some ways,
like looking in a mirror, in other words,
both synthetic and statue were perfect creations
that would long outlive their human creators.
Intriguingly though, the choice of David and
Walter for the names of the two synthetics
in Alien: Covenant is actually an homage to
the producers of all the Alien movies.
Alien: Covenant features the drinking bird
toy that has appeared in several of the Alien
movies, starting with Ridley Scott's 1979
film.
I'm curious as to whether this is just an
easter egg or whether there's a deeper meaning
to the repeated placement of the toy bird
on various ships.
Perhaps it's just a fun souvenir from home.
Or could it suggest the monotony of their
lives on board?
Or maybe the reason it's there is hinted at
in Prometheus where a programmed message plays
after the crew wake up, encouraging them to
drink enough water.
Along with the original Alien movie, one of
Ridley Scott's best-known sci-fi films is
1982's Blade Runner starring Harrison Ford,
and there are a number of easter eggs and
possible links between Blade Runner and Alien:
Covenant.
For example, this emergency signal which appears
in Blade Runner also appears in Covenant as
well as Prometheus.
And one of the scenes in Alien: Covenant tips
its hat to a scene in Blade Runner.
When Daniels uses a nail to stab David, he
mocks her saying "that's the spirit!"
In Blade Runner, Batty impales his own hand
with a nail and moments later taunts Deckard
as they fight with the line "that's the spirit!"
Ridley Scott is also a producer on the sequel,
Blade Runner 2049, and that movie's trailer
teases a suspended humanoid figure which bears
some similarity to the Engineers from the
Alien movies.
With both films coming out this year and apparent
easter eggs and references between the two
movies, could this be Ridley Scott hinting
at a possible shared universe?
Talking of crossovers, there's a nod to Predator
in the scene on the Covenant where the alien
chases Daniels and Tennessee through the ship.
We get a point-of-view shot for the alien as
it hunts the remaining pair of crew members.
But the Predator franchise is no stranger
to this type of POV shot, and of course, that
franchise crossed over with the Alien franchise
in the Alien vs Predator movies.
So, were there any other easter eggs or Alien
connections you spotted in Alien: Covenant?
And what do you think about a possible crossover
between Alien and Blade Runner?
Don't forget to comment about the movie and
subscribe for your chance to win one of these
[two] awesome Alien: Covenant merch packs.
Be sure to turn on notifications for my new
videos where I'll be announcing the winners.
If you liked the video, do please hit that
thumbs-up button and you can check out more
of my Alien and easter egg videos by tapping
the screen right here!
Thanks for watching and see you next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!